[Music]
that's good one 1ls me why Jimmy on the
drachmas soap your face will up guitar
some other keys and we end like yo 40 in
it already gets running with it a little
bit of Sony minutes and seconds I'm
moving all the business apply without
falling my first - or warning ready The
Diamonds life but was given reasoning
with Egon thought it goes what up me
he's gonna do now diljit with the
refrain of me stepping through stop
please don't take a page from me with a
mint agency and do the sweep in fact
that if they can know let's configure
server she was never a mechanic we FN s
3 plus mana me question you're gonna be
here in the crash so when I'm here see
you mean s capitalist common investment
will not be get them in a sec so in a
crustacean a 400 nm Jeff she's me but
it's the ones got a monster not be your
best or in a bless them in the stress
the probably next meeting is a sting in
Oviedo in the present world I wanna
Mozambicans in the way is it yes tell
emigrate preference I know you will
never forget
the killers or maybe only ucsf oda
dominguez people they've been denoted
enemies Diaz ahna go seek the Africa
cause of the scope watching approach at
my last show
ridiculous or maybe don't need to see
his opponent and they just be what they
made it loaded up in a mean theological
think that are recorded also watching
them for a mile I feel our vision
killers are maybe don't need only in the
morning as they do me what they mean
they noted underneath the along devotees
to every for desk or watching on 12
testify
[Music]
just so many people they may be named
people think of her fingers believe the
jinx they go bigger but not the teaser
more knowledge so he could say it's a
hobby you can claim it's a hustle
pontificate on that one ball a little
bit but after I leave their idiot waffle
don't even intellect open the Japanese
your waffle and Bernie atop the drop of
puzzles or play the subtle way to go are
you coming up all my love willing crush
such a map or reason exceeds negative
store but doctor looks one line people
thought they final stages when they come
to my are only Baja first a control our
vision killers or maybe only just yes a
moaning and they don't be what they mean
did know that are there as easy a long
ago seeking a record to the slope
watching for a trial I've shown they
summers and killers or maybe only to see
his opponent and they don't be what they
mean is all about the enemy be a long
ago seek to every proposal to stop
watching as long as I live show what you
never broke with my life show yo
Daisy yes people
[Music]
yeah yeah sure what my vision killers or
maybe don't need your siesta Mona and
they can be anything they loaded up in a
PC as long ago ceased America water the
soap worked in a grope at my last show
Thanks don't be jealous or maybe only
just to get the morning and they'd just
be what they been denoted us in a PC you
longer gonna pickle more to the soap
what's in a broke-ass my large oh yeah
Jay